Today in history, on June 19th, the year
1097, Christians of the first crusade
achieved their first victory over
invading Islam at Nika, where the first
universal Christian creed was formulated
and recited. First, some background. In
the years following the decisive battle
of Manzikert in 1071, when the Seljic
Turks defeated the Eastern Roman Empire
and overran that ancient bastion of
Christianity, Anatolia, today modern-day
Turkey, countless atrocities were
committed. Whether an anonymous Georgian
chronicler told of how quote holy
churches served as stables for their
horses, the priests were immolated
during the holy communion itself, the
virgins defiled, the youth circumcised
and the infants taken away or whether
ana the princess at Constantinople told
of how quote cities were obliterated,
lands were plundered and the whole of
Anatolia was stained with Christian
blood. It was the same scandalous tale
of woe that reached Europe, Western
Europe. As a result, what came to be
known as history's first crusade was
launched. Paraphrasing Pope Urban II's
famous call at Claremont in 1095,
Crusades historian Thomas Madden wrote,
quote, "The message was clear. Christ
was crucified again in the persecution
of his faithful and the defilement of
his sanctuaries."
Both needed rescuing. Both offered an
opportunity to fulfill one of Christ's
two greatest commandments. Love God with
all your heart and love your neighbor as
yourself. Luke 10:27.
So Christians from all around Europe
hearkened to the call and took the
cross. By 1097 the major lords and
knights had reached Constantinople once
they were fed into the lion's den Turkey
controlled Asia Minor. Then by May they
had reached Nika site of
Christrysendom's first ecumenical
council where the Nyian creed which is
still professed by all major Christian
denominations Catholic Orthodox
Protestant was articulated in 325.
Now it was the capital of the Seljic
Sultanate and occupied by the quote
unquote enemies of the cross as the
Muslims were known. The crusaders began
the siege of then Muslim occupied Nika
on May 14th, 1097. It was long and
brutal, but the Turks held their own.
From their high walls, the Muslims quote
shouted their warlike battlecry in the
horrible tones of their language. The
contemporary chronicler Albert of Akan
wrote not being able to decipher the
wellrecoognized cries of Allah Akbar
then and they fired poisoned arrows so
that even those lightly wounded met a
horrible death he wrote. Moreover, in
order to defend their walls from being
struck and shaken repeatedly by the
battering ram, the Turks created a
combustible mixture and poured it over
the walls which torched the battering
ram. Smoke, fire, and screams rose as
the siege dragged on. On May 20th,
Kilage Arcelin, the Seljic Sultan and
Supreme Head of the Turks, appeared with
a massive Muslim army, to deliver Nika,
then his capital. A wild battle ensued.
Albert of Akan continues. Quote, "Duke
Godfrey and Bohand, then being two
leaders of the first crusade, did not
curb their horses, but flew in the midst
of the enemy, piercing some with lances,
unsaddling others, and all the while
urging on their allies, encouraging them
with manly exhortations to slaughter the
enemy. There was no small clash of
spears there. No small rings of swords
and helmets heard in this conflict of
the war, no small destruction of the
Turks. But it was the greater force of
the crusader army under the command of
Raymond of Tulus with aid from Count
Robert of Flanders that gave the Muslim
army its death stroke, routing them. In
this the inaugural battle of the first
crusade, quote, the Arabs, Persians, and
ferocious Turks soon fled. The savage
people showed their backs to the
Christians. It was a route prodiguous
was the slaughter of the fleeing army.
From the 3rd until the 9th hour, the
destruction or rather Arabian slaughter
of this battle raged. This triumphant
description is not so much invention and
bias on the part of Gibbe of Nojon as it
is in fact a reflection of the fact that
this vast Muslim army was not made of
professional soldiers but largely
consisted of quote peasants and scum
herded together from everywhere. Later
Turkish armies would be more formidable.
Having slaughtered countless Muslims,
the Westerners resumed the siege of Nika
in order to make clear to its Turkish
occupiers that they could no longer hope
to be delivered from outside aid. The
crusaders quote lobbed the severed heads
of the slaughtered Turks from their
throwing machines and catapults to the
city to quote Robert the monk. There was
of course a reason that the crusaders
behaved so ruthlessly. Earlier on first
landing in Anatolia they had encountered
a horrific sight. Quote, "Oh how many
severed heads and bones of the dead
lying on the plains did we then find
beyond Nikomedia near the sea?" wrote
the eyewitness fulchure of Chartra.
Moved to compassion by this, we shed
many tears there. They had come upon the
remains of all those European commoners,
men, women, and children that were too
impatient to wait for the professional
knights at Constantinople, and so had
crossed into Asia Minor alone against
Emperor Alexius's
council. Soon after landing in the Nyian
inland in 1096, they fell into the
Turkish ambuscade and were miserably
slaughtered, wrote Princess Anna Kenna,
adding that quote, "So great a multitude
of Kelts and Normans died by the
Ishmaelite sword. That when they
gathered the remains of the fallen lying
on every side, they heaped up, I will
not say a mighty ridge or hill or peak,
but a mountain of considerable height
and depth and width. So huge was the
mass of bones."
The Christians who were captured at this
time underwent a different trial. In the
words of Gair, quote, "Some of the
prisoners were challenged about their
faith and ordered to renounce Christ,
but they proclaimed Christ with steady
heart and voiced and were decapitated.
The fate of those kept alive as usual,
the young and was often worse." He
continues, quote, "The Turks divided up
among themselves some of the captives
whose lives they had spared, or rather
reserved for for a more painful death
and submitted them to dismal servitude
at the hands of cruel masters. Some were
exposed in public like targets and were
pierced by arrows. Others were given
away as gifts, while others were sold
outright and taken to Muslim lands where
they would endure wretched slavery under
the worst masters imaginable. They
underwent a torture much longer than
that endured by those whose heads were
severed swiftly by the sword. Indeed,
how the Islamic lords of Turk controlled
Asia Minor must have laughed then,
having annihilated the indigenous
Christian population of Anatolia, now
European Christians were marching in for
the same exact treatment. But they were
not laughing now. Along with the many
Muslim heads the crusaders were lobbing
into Nika, another 1,000 of these heads
were sent to the Eastern Roman Emperor,
a present which won his hearty favor.
Unsurprisingly so, as these were the
same men who had sacked and slaughtered
all the Christians of Nika in 1092, just
5 years earlier when it was still ruled
by the Christian emperor. He responded
by sending more supplies, including
muchneeded boats for the crusaders to
cut off Nika's only supply route. "These
the crusaders during the course of one
night by ropes placed on the shoulders
and necks of men and horses, dragged to
Nika a distance of 7 mi or more," wrote
William of tear. Soon thereafter, on
June 19th, 1097, that is on today's
date, the now overly traumatized Turks,
these longtime scourges of Eastern
Christendom, surrendered Nika on
condition that they capitulate not to
the heavily armored newcomers from the
west who had so terrorized them, but to
Emperor Alexius, who had followed the
crusaders with his own army.
Thus, the first crusade began with a
magnificent victory over the Muslim
invaders, witnessing the liberation of a
site so important to early Christendom,
Nika. Okay, there it is. For more on the
Crusades, see my book, Sword and
Scimitar, which this video was based on.
Bye.